[Music]
what up guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
and we got two daddies and a baby today
two daddies and a baby
yeah let us know in the comments below
if you like this whole series maybe
we'll bring it back again
don't forget to hit thumbs up and share
with all your friends and turn on all
the notifications
and finally we're being good youtubers
15 years later i feel like all the good
ones they know
but we never do that to keep it real
yeah if you share it only if you like it
who cares about
you know if the channel grows or
anything i um i want to get
like a space like let's say a shed or a
warehouse
where we can pitch in and just like get
a ton of cars
that's what i'm thinking about a ton of
cars yeah like different
after buying my car i'm just going down
the rabbit hole now of like
wait what card you get the land cruiser
the 1988 yeah and then i want bike i
want more bikes and
cars more toys and [ __ ] way more men i
want more
like um some some people i follow
like you know when people when they have
like so many cars that they like it
doesn't have to be necessarily expensive
but they just have like
a lot of cars that they like they'll end
up getting like a garage
like somewhere else like some big-ass
warehouse and they could just park it in
there
that'd be tight where would it be that
would be in vegas i mean
it depends on where i'm at i guess
because it's expensive here
should i get one vegas no because if
it's vegas we can get in together you
know
that'll be cheaper i got a buddy who
owns
a motorcycle shop and he does
scramblers and he wants to build
like the jk crew a bunch oh cool yeah so
then
we all go out and like ride them and
then like
you know he's not gonna give it to us
but we can
go out and the cool thing with them is
like it's off-road capable
so we can go into the forest with it and
then like just park it wherever
and then do camping and whatever so i
get to
kind of have or use one without owning
it
i kind of like it you know you know
there's like all these like different
apps now where you can just rent it's
like turtle right so you can like rent
different motorcycles or rvs or whatever
yeah i feel like you could rent anything
you could probably like rent a boat you
could probably write all kinds of [ __ ]
now
yeah you could rent like a van life like
they
they deck out the van for like van life
living you could rent mourners for your
funeral
what there's a fear of dying alone yeah
so people that don't want to like
have anyone like no one show up to their
funeral uh you can
and uh you can rent people to show up
and like actually mourn crybabies.com
yeah i don't want a funeral no
i don't want people to even recognize
that i'm dead
you know people just think you're alive
if i'm dead you guys are not allowed to
recognize that you should i'm on
vacation oh where's joe at he's on
vacation like 10 years of backlogged uh
youtube video scheduled for when after
you die yeah so you actually
interstellar [ __ ] just act like you're
traveling
and then uh that then you're like just
kidding guys i've been there for 10
years
oh so it's like a um what do you call
those things when like
it's like when you die it goes on and it
happens
yeah like those automatic like not a
kill switch it's like the opposite of
one but like
when people are like if you watch this
video that means the cia got a hold of
me yeah yeah
yeah it's it's kind of like one of those
right so like as soon as i go
then it starts the the videos it starts
to go off
you should [ __ ] with people and be like
like say like they have a funeral for
you
but then you post a video that's
scheduled like a week after your death
uh be like just be like it's like you
it's hella dark you have like a match
and it looks like you're in a coffin
you're like
i don't know how i got signal but i'm
posting this video come get me
open it guys open it that would be crazy
yeah but what if i recorded that video
and then like by the time
i'm 70 i finally die then it's like
my 30 ass yeah you're recording i was
like come on what the [ __ ] dude you got
to stockpile too early i don't
you got to record it like every year
yeah or then just release them
that's true so exactly the regular vlogs
right so you're always like 30
or like 30 videos ahead 30 views 30
years ahead there goes joe again
i don't know man i i do like cars
but before i never really got into like
the engine and the fixing and the parts
and i just liked appreciating it and
driving it and watching it are you like
depreciating it
no no like appreciating like the
aesthetics of it yeah how it looks and
then like you can modify it or whatever
but then
um it never interested me to personally
get hands-on
and fix things does it now or you still
don't now i do no you do
i don't know what changed it it just
makes me want to
fix stuff yeah once you have something
that's like you have to take care of
it teaches you to because you've had
nice cars but you kept it to the experts
and it wasn't like also you owned owned
them
in a sense i've always had project cars
though like i had a drift car
uh you had a 200 sx and um
i was pretty rough with it in the engine
blue
um and then i had a supra and then that
burned to the ground
and i was doing small adjustments on it
but
it was always like one of those things
where i felt irresponsible blowing money
on it so i
i always owned cars where i'm like oh
yeah
i can i can play with this stock
like it's a rear-wheel drive so i could
drift with it right
but then i never spent that extra to get
wheels
to like you know get a spoiler or or do
the things that like
most teens do maybe you always viewed it
as like a transportation vehicle
so like as that i think we're all
programmed to think
that cars are like a depreciating like
asset
but um i think people that just love
cars they just see it as like a giant
like model airplane yeah maybe you're
starting to see it like that now
i think so cause then i didn't have that
much money
back then so even though i had these
like cool little cars i never fixed it
up
so it's like i had just enough to buy
the car yeah yeah
and then i didn't add more to fix the
car yeah
but now i can so like now i'm like oh
this locks broken
i'm gonna buy a freaking new lock and
then fix it or whatever
and it also feels like you're connected
more with it like
like you like almost like a sense you
always appreciate it but like
once you actually put the time and
effort into it it becomes that much more
like yours and unique to you yeah but
now that i
have this and it was meant for over
landing now i want another one that i
can beat up
i don't want to take this one note
anymore i know it's like the
you know the asian concept of saran
wrapping the remotes yeah
it's like i don't want this to i want
this to look perfect
all the time that's what i ended up
having like you know in my safe
my gun safe uh the guns that i really
liked i ended up buying two of them
like i have like i did that too like
this one is the one
that's the safe queen this is the one
that i'm actually gonna use
so like one is like for display but it's
always in the safe you're not even
you're not even looking at it i know i'm
not right
that's true it's like kind of it's kind
of dumb if you think about it yeah i got
two glocks
because i mean you can buy a glock
anywhere right but i'm like
if this one gets lost
this is my back but there's also a
hundred of them
in the store i know yeah i don't get
that because for me it's like i i feel
like it's just gonna waste
but also i don't got money like y'all
yeah i don't know i think maybe it's
like
viewing it like you know how like some
people really like one pair of shoes so
they buy
two of them this one i i'll wear every
day beat it up and this one
but then with the stuff that you're
supposed to use like guns it is kind of
dumb
because for me it's like if i had one
glock and i was like let me buy another
one
now i'm like wow
i'm shooting two guys at the same time
oh you know uh why for me specifically
was the stippling like that on the the
stippling work i wanted this dude
he was really good i wanted him to do
two so then it made it
unique where it's like this and then you
know
i don't even have a contact to this guy
no more so it was like a friend of a
friend who did it
yeah i did like my own stippling and
that gun became like that much more
like unique to me and like i knew like
every time i shoot it or
like hold it it's like i did this
compared to like someone else doing it
that's true i had the opposite so i used
to work on
car audios a lot and when i had my first
tacoma
um i didn't do it right so there's you
mean you did the wiring that the wiring
and like i used to work on my car mike's
car chris's car richard's car like we
used to do car audios all the time
and then like once uh i got tacoma i
gotta like the military had more money
so like people are into car audio from
high school to getting a little bit more
money like the goal is this thing called
component systems
where it's not just plug and play
anymore like every speaker needs an amp
and i'm like [ __ ] that's what i'm
finally gonna do but then the speaker is
like that much thicker
and so if you don't do it right um when
the window comes down
it'll stop so my passenger side window
it never went down
so every time that i was like driving
i'm like [ __ ] i knew i should have paid
a profession
was it everyone's goal to get that jail
audio base though
yeah yeah yeah dang i had that in the
trunk it was rattling my [ __ ] license
plate no so i was like i think from that
it made me go and when i have money i'm
gonna pay professionals to do but i also
get
when when you are your own craftsman
like you feel that much more connected
to it too it's crazy though like once i
actually got a car i actually like and
it started making a little more money
putting money in the right places and
not spending it stupidly like
proper insurance instead of spending a
lot of money on insurance true that
thank goodness
this episode is brought to you by gabby
insurance
yeah it is because a lot of people are
out there overpaying for car insurance
and home insurance
and they don't even know and so just
with
going online you can save yourself a lot
of money you have to spend all kinds of
hours doing your research with gabby did
you know that the
gabby customers save 960
dollars per year on average that's
almost a thousand
extra dollars in your pocket and gabby
takes the paint out of shopping for
insurance by giving you an
apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage
so they're taking the same things the
deductible what it covers and they're
making sure it's exactly the same and
they're comparing
the top 40 insurance providers like
progressive
nationwide and travelers all you have to
do is link your
current insurance account in just
minutes you'll be able to see quotes
for the exact same coverage you
currently have yup so check this out you
guys know that i got a new ride
that i'm super happy with it is the 1988
land cruiser by toyota and i had to ask
gaby yo
what kind of quotes can you get and they
got me a few here that i'm gonna list
off
safeco was 89 bucks a month progressive
was 93
allstate was 94. travelers was 97
so roughly compared to my current
provider
i did a little calculation and they
would save me
about 35 bucks a month if i
go through them but if you add it up
annually
like that's over 400 bucks so that's a
that's a lot of money to save
and you know they're gonna be covering
pretty much the same kind of
like stuff on the premium so i thought
that was pretty fair and awesome and
it's dope that there's something like
this
out there and now you can just type it
in
your information and it's really quick
and easy and simple i did it myself
i did it like in less than five minutes
and i was able to get all those quotes
so if you're interested
in saving on car or home insurance see
how much gabby can save you it's totally
free to check
and there's no obligation just go to
gabby.com off the record
that's gabi.com the record
gabby.com off record and see how much
gabby can save you
yeah i want a lot of cars too uh like
recently i showed you the car that i
grew up in so
um growing up my mom had a 1984
uh pontiac monte carlo which is funny
because at that time it was just like a
american sedan but now it's like one of
the go-to like lowriders that people
like
so it's so i think to me it holds a
special place in my heart because like
it's it's the car that i grew up going
to preschool in and i see it as my mom's
car
but on the flip side it could be
gangster as [ __ ] so like that's one of
the cars i want
my all-time favorite is 67 chevelle i
also like old school toyotas
like there's just so many cars and like
it would be tight if i'm able to get
like a warehouse yeah jay leno's
warehouse and like park it all in there
that'd be so [ __ ] cool
i really want like i would want three
cars i feel like having too many that i
don't get to play with them all and like
do a lot of stuff and i gotta go to
waste what are the three cars i would
want like a big truck
right like a really nice truck off-road
style off-road like uh
like yeah where i could still drive you
know
um kind of like a good like in between
yeah um
then i'd want like a nice sports car
like a porsche
oh yeah so it's kind of classy and then
like an old like
either like one of those like old
convertible astons or like mercedes
like a classy car like a classy car yeah
but like the old ones
but like it's like a cruise one too
where it's like you're not driving fast
windows down
tops down just blasting music like you
know the car in a
hangover the one they borrowed their
dad's silver mercedes yeah something
like that
that's [ __ ] clean or like an old like
james bond aston that one's cool too
yeah
i want an ice cream truck like borah
yeah that's [ __ ] dumb like have
candy cannons where you just go up to
neighborhoods and [ __ ] blast kids
with it
like boom boom boom boom and then it
just [ __ ] flies in the air like
confetti
and then and then it's like free candy
ice cream
you just go up and then like our music
will be like
every day go to school right and then
you just
just hook them up with like sundays
popsicles whatever
oh man that would suck because all the
other ice cream trucks would hate me
dude they're like what the [ __ ] why are
you giving out free inventory like that
you [ __ ]
i like uh the dumb and dumber car too
the dog
dude i would get ridiculous [ __ ] like
that all day
how do you wash that [ __ ] you gotta
vacuum it and shampoo it
should get so dirty yeah i watch this
one car
youtuber that i found like i don't know
why it took me so long to find this dude
but his name is like
chris fix right and um
he just basically teaches you how to fix
your car
with simple household tools and
he does some dope projects man he's like
yeah he found his car for like 500 bucks
and then he
pretty much got it running again and all
this stuff and he just knows a lot
yeah but i'm like you have to know a lot
about it
to be able to fix it with like the bare
minimum yeah
if i were to make a dog car i think i
would have to first of all
start with a toyota because i know i'll
last forever
and then get one that's like you know
the toyotas like before they
enter into the classic price range where
it starts going back up yeah
so i got to find something probably like
mid-90s or something
so something that's right there was a
rock bottom price but i know i'll still
last
a good easy hundred thousand and then i
gotta take it to like a car shop
and kind of convince them to make it
because because they probably got like
the sickest wraps
and the sickest wheels but i'm like hey
do you guys have fur
i need ears and [ __ ] shag my dad always
wanted me to get like a
like a really beat up like he wanted
with like a house too like
an old house and like it looks bad on
the outside
or like a bad car just beat up and stuff
but the inside is like
perfect engine the seats are the perfect
everything about the car is amazing
just the outside looks horrible why does
he want to look horrible i don't know my
dad's weird
for fun i don't know he's like so people
like they don't look at it and then they
think
it's unassuming but then you beat them
all the time in like races or whatever
he wants to be a sleeper
yeah i mean imagine getting like a
lamborghini
but then you put like a giraffe costume
on it
that's great no one knows you know no
one knows it's a sports car or whatever
you just roll up
dude that'll be the best man like you
turn it into a [ __ ] float
oh my god if you got stupid money
that'd be fun i feel like we could do
that right now
with and we don't even got that much
like if
if we got like let's say you get a llama
for like 100k
no no like i'm talking about like a fast
card that's cheap
right i think about the dog car i think
i could do one for 10 grand you could
probably
yeah no i think you could do it for less
than 10. yeah i feel like
you could do it for you could get a
decent car for like
two to three grand like a big suv or
like a van
right and then you just gotta find
the fabric for the dog yeah and then you
cutting in
that should be pretty easy that's true
yeah you could do it for less than five
grand dude
maybe for like three maybe when i move
next year
dude that's gonna be our vegas project
the dog car yeah
and then we build a dog car we gotta try
to sell it i love it
the goal is to make money off it yeah
who's gonna buy it
someone will dude let's do it
i don't know anyone that's gonna be dumb
enough to buy a [ __ ] there's dumb people
on
i'm pretty sure we're gonna make money
doing it guys that [ __ ] cars
that's true so so he's gonna someone's
gonna walk the car
you gotta find someone that is into
[ __ ] cars and bestiality
that's like their dream car what why
can't it just be a goofy person that
wants to buy
because if you saw that [ __ ] if you're
browsing around like
auto trader right and you saw a dog car
you would buy it in a heartbeat if it
was 4gs
and if it was a toyota right because i
know that i don't know if we can find a
toyota
i don't know because i also want it to
work like i think my dream
my dream dog car would probably be like
a 90s forerunner
with pretty dope like shocks
so if we go shoot too i could go
off-roading you see a dog going through
the desert
oh she has some drone shots of this dog
tell me inside
and it is his ears flap and the tail
flaps
so when you see the car bouncing high
you gotta like uh he's all dusty later
was it in dumb dumber where like you
have to have like a leg that you lift to
put in the gas
so it looks like it's kissing every time
dude that'll be the best oh we gotta
build this dude this has to be a project
car
we gotta do it man or oh or another one
would be funny if we did a prank show
where we have a like a stretched
limousine
but it's slammed so every driveway we go
and it's like
and we get stuck and we'll get stuck on
a [ __ ] bump
yeah it'd be funny just to record
everyone's reactions like
who's dumb enough to [ __ ] slam the
limousine
that's tight you should get a lifted one
let's take it off running oh my god we
gotta do it like off-road limousine it's
like
can we even find a limo these days
everywhere
everywhere i haven't seen a limo in ages
i saw a g wagon um limo i saw
a um a range rolls-royce no rolls-royce
uh limo and i'm like what the [ __ ] damn
do rolls-royce make that or does it some
other company i think somebody might
yeah make it yeah or do they like how do
they how do they make them do they buy
two of them and then they put it
together this is like five of them long
no i think they cut it in the middle and
then they stretch it out but it looks
like it's the same parts it looks
seamless too
really yeah and in the inside it's
always like some u-shaped couch too
that shit's crazy i hate limos you don't
like limos no whenever we get them for
for vegas to like travel i'm just like
this is
because you can't drink in them like you
you can i guess but
it's not as fun as like just let me get
to the party but sometimes it's
it's because they're cheap they're cheap
yeah because i'll come taxi they're
[ __ ] sitting there for a taxi and the
limo guy would just come up to me like
dude give me 20 bucks i'll take you
anywhere i'm like what
i'm like [ __ ] yeah isn't it funny
because limo's supposed to be luxurious
yeah but everyone's just trying to
hustle and make money so they're like
because nobody wants to buy it
yeah they're just sitting there
[Music]
you